[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france 24 el
texto de una nueva constitución chilena
fue ampliamente rechazado por 62% de los
votantes el pasado 4 de septiembre
ahora el presidente de gabriel boliche
busca ampliar su gobernabilidad para
crear un nuevo texto que sea aceptado y
que finalmente reemplace la carta magna
hecha en tiempos de dictadura mientras
tanto la campaña por el apruebo vive un
momento de decepción entre sus
promotoras están las colectivas por los
derechos de las mujeres y es que el
texto rechazado iba a ser una de las
constituciones más feministas del mundo
sobre las causas de este rechazo y lo
que se podría plantear para el futuro
vamos a analizar y para ello nos
acompañan karina en ojales quien es
vocera de la coordinadora feminista 8m
en chile carine se encuentra en el
santiago la capital chilena y también
nos acompaña desde santiago y ve
d'andrea fuensalida analista y
profesional en ciencias sociales y
comunicación muchísimas gracias a ambos
por estar en ellas hoy
muchas gracias
angela por esta oportunidad de analizar
es este gran dolor que significó para la
feminista del abl el haber rechazado el
domingo por amplia mayoría bueno pues
entonces entremos en materia quisiera
comenzar con karina cuál es esa
sensación que queda después de la
victoria del desapruebo en la votación
ciudadana
muchas preguntas en realidad y yo creo
que no van a ser tan
de responder
estamos ante una elección que por
primera vez
obliga a la participación de todas las
personas mayores de edad en el país
y es todo esto
cambiar de una manera bastante
inesperada el comportamiento electoral
largamente ha pensado en las últimas
colecciones del país
en segundo lugar una de las preguntas
que articula el análisis es que es lo
que rechazó la gente cuando rescató en
este sentido no es posible afirmar
categóricamente que lo que fue rechazado
por la propuesta de nueva constitución
claro es muy difícil entender realmente
qué partes del texto fueron las que la
ciudadanía definitivamente no quería
adoptar para para su vida diaria y aquí
quiero preguntarle y ver después claro
en este proceso entra ahora la tarea de
reconocer que hay que reformular algunas
cosas no hay de otra porque perdió
fuerza a la campaña del apruebo claro
yo creo que perdió fuerza
significativamente por la campaña del
terror que hizo la derecha
[Música]
porque era una propuesta absolutamente
garantista de derechos sociales
y la derecha había amenazado su postura
frente
y sin embargo y verde ante este este
gran
movimiento movilizador que lo que hizo
fue generar el rechazo de este texto que
durante más de un año fue redactado pues
en su opinión habría que reformular
algunas cosas claro en este caso en
materia feminista usted cree que habría
que reformular o plantear de una manera
diferente esta garantía por los derechos
de las mujeres
yo creo que no necesariamente
él
la postura y la forma en cómo trabajó la
asamblea constituyente es histórica es
primera vez que un órgano o es paritario
y creo que desde esa perspectiva no
tenemos porque es reformar y sobre todo
en materia de género y de derechos
fundamentales para las mujeres cariño
hasta que opina greg que si tendríamos
que hacer algún tipo de reformulación es
de lo que estaba escrito
hay análisis que diría apresurados que
plantean que el texto la nueva
constitución fue rechazado por ser
maximalistas
que contenía demasiado derecha para las
que la sociedad chilena no estaba
preparado ya no estoy de acuerdo con
este análisis
porque la población los juegos de
rechazo porque estaba en contra por
ejemplo del reconocimiento de los
trabajos domésticos directiva 2 o en
forma del reconocimiento del derecho a
una vida libre de violencia de género a
la niña y mujeres hiciera ser falsa
no más bien de voto a partir de un
desconocimiento esta forma hubo una
campaña de desinformación como el ibex y
por otro lado ese tipo de normas
similarmente las de quienes opositan una
gestión bastante tranquila embargo esa
adhesión
para desinstalar entidad
perón determinante para que la población
para por ejemplo
con la nueva constitución nueva haber 3
que la vivienda tokio y van a quedar los
de pensiones y las dos porque el país
que iba dirigido en el actur y las
salidas estas mentiras que no eran
parque tec pero más fuerzas exteriores y
siguen estando con ampliada de éstos
hasta daniel pienso que dice son las
mercedes
bueno usted está mencionando un tema
importante
karina y antes de continuar con la
siguiente pregunta le quiero pedir que
sea cómodo un poco el micrófono porque
la escuchamos un poco entrecortada y
mientras tanto pues se vive de retomó
con usted para hablar sobre esta parte
de la propuesta que fue una de las más
polémicas y es el tema del planteamiento
de un estado plurinacional en un país
donde el 13% de los ciudadanos pues se
pertenecen a etnias y a comunidades
indígenas y que algunos expertos
analizan que habría podido redactarse de
una manera un poco diferente pues para
que hubiera quedado la gente más
satisfecho estoy qué opina
yo estoy absolutamente acuerdo como como
fue redactada
yo creo que hubo mucha desinformación
mucha noticia falsa que diciendo que
iban desde que la justicia no tenía por
qué ser diferente para mapuches
o de cualquier etnia frente a los
chilenos y nunca fue así el concepto de
plurinacionalidad se refería a reconocer
nuestros ancestros y los lugares y
territorios que tenían todos los pueblos
indígenas
reconocer sus culturas sus costumbres
sus religiones
entonces creo que eso no habría que
cambiarlo yo estaría a favor de
mantenerlo bueno entonces vamos a darle
un poco la vuelta al enfoque de la
entrevista para plantear lo que ustedes
quieren plantear y es como deberían
estar estructurados los derechos de las
mujeres en un eventual nuevo texto para
reemplazar la constitución de la época
de pinochet karina en que se
concentraron para esta primera redacción
y que esperan que aparezca en el nuevo
texto
bueno en el trabajo de la conducción al
edificio la posibilidad de construir
normas a través de iniciativas o plan el
trabajo de las constituyen tenis en
conjunto con las organizaciones que es
pérez feministas del país posición
construir todas las normas y que fueron
rechazadas en el nuevo texto a través de
iniciativas de tal variedad director del
equipo de violencia derechos sexuales y
reproductivos
el reconocimiento de los trabajadores
cuidados y enfoque decidido en este tema
de visual y eso para nosotras tiene
visos irrenunciable para tentar el
próximo proceso constituyente que está
pasando hoy en el parlament o no a
solicitud del ejecutivo nos parece que
son demandas que no han sido históricas
sino que están buscando y que están
refrendados un movimiento que ha logrado
convocar a las movilizaciones más
grandes no sólo de la historia lo que
también de este ciclo de movilizaciones
de los últimos 30 años de democracia
el movimiento feminista no está pensando
hoy generar paso atrás o retroceder de
las demandas planteadas eso es una
cuestión no y otra cuestión y me quedé
por el incierto escenario en que nos
coloca este resultado con una
participación tan pero tan masiva como
poder llegar a aquellos sectores tan
amplios y tan empobrecido que
mayoritariamente strong agota rechazo
que nunca pudieron conocer la propuesta
que se sometía a deliberación como
afirma muy bien nuestra constituyente
alondra carrillo para votar rechazo no
hacía falta tener una televisora placas
para votar apruebo hacía falta que una
persona llegará directamente a dialogar
a cada rincón y territorio del files por
ahí transcurre más bien las tareas en
este nuevo escenario que también se ve
de ser lanzado en el sentido que ir
nuevos casos o constituyente que se está
pactando
probablemente va a ser con una
participación mucho más acotada
despreciables y va a quedar depositada
en los partidos que durante estos 30
años al administrador de neoliberal que
hacen lados también por la población
y en ese sentido ya para ir cerrando y
ver después en qué debe enfocarse ahora
el trabajo feminista para esforzarnos o
esforzarse más bien las mujeres chilenas
para que estas ideas y estas necesidades
por los derechos de las mujeres queden
consignadas en una nueva carta magna
para chile'
e
[Música]
yo creo que vamos a tener que conversar
mucho
yo no estoy muy de acuerdo con la forma
que se va a redactar la nueva
constitución hasta el día de hoy todavía
no sabemos si va a ser a través de una
asamblea constituyente a través del
parlamento
si es en el parlamento yo veo que va a
ser para ti timo el nivel de
participación femenina
ellos no tienen el concepto asumido el
concepto de paridad y creo que eso es un
punto que no hay que transar para para
la redacción de la nueva constitución
bueno y está también el tema del aborto
que no solamente es uno de los más
polémicos en chile- y alrededor de los
países latinoamericanos sino uno de los
puntos que ustedes no estaban dispuestas
a negociar y es esta garantía por los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos por
favor ella para el cierre y beth
solamente le quiero pedir uno de paneo
grande de lo que ustedes aspiran a que
aparezca en el tema de derechos sexuales
y reproductivos
sobre todo yo creo que educación sexual
en los colegios
para las niñas y niños en edad escolar
y también que la maternidad sea una
decisión íntima de cada mujer que no se
imponga a través de una ley o de una
constitución que sea cada mujer la que
delibere el su sentir íntimo todo todo
lo relacionado con su sexualidad y los
métodos anticonceptivos para usar pues
ibd y karina los resultados ya se dieron
el proceso cambio y ahora estamos a la
espera de que chile nuevamente se
encamine para continuar con este proceso
constituyente a ustedes gracias por
haber estado con nosotros en ellas hoy
lamentablemente el tiempo es
inmensamente corto para poder abordar
tantos temas que estaban consignados en
este proyecto de constitución pero el
agradecimiento también para nuestros
televidentes por estar con nosotros y
nos vemos su próximamente en ella soy
[Música]